In this section, we're going to cover drug research and that includes drugs as
medicine and drugs of abuse. We're going to look at both basic and applied
research. Meaning, the basic side is experiments conducted to gather basic
information on what drugs do to the body and the brain. And on the applied
side, we're going to look at ways that drugs can be used to help the human
condition. There's a lot of things we're going to consider in this lesson.
We're going to look at why do people take drugs. We're going to look at how
drugs work to produce their effects. We're going to look at physical and
psychological dependence as well as tolerance and withdrawal. We're also going
to look at how the root of administration plays an important role in the
reinforcing effects of drugs. We're going to look at how set and setting can
influence drug effects. We'll look at how genetics play a role in drug use and
abuse. We'll also look at how drugs are studied with animals and humans to
discover effective treatments for a variety of conditions. We'll also look at
specific classes of drugs and their physical, behavioral and psychological
effects. Also, how drugs are used to expand consciousness and very importantly,
treatments for drug abuse.